- [Instructor] Olga was asked to find
where f of x is equal to x
minus two to the fourth power
has inflection points.
This is her solution.
So we look at her solution
and then they ask us,
is Olga's work correct?
If not, what's her mistake?
So pause this video and see
if you can figure this out.
Alright, let's just follow her work.
So here, she's trying to
take the first derivative.
So you would apply the chain rule.
It would be four times x
minus two to the third power
times the derivative of x
minus two which is just one.
So this checks out.
Then you take the derivative of this.
It'd be three times four which would be 12
times x minus two to the second power
times the derivative of x
minus two which is just one
which is exactly what she has here,
12 times x minus two to the second power.
That checks out so step
one's looking good for Olga.
Step two, the solution
of the second derivative
equaling zero is x equals two.
That looks right.
The second derivative is 12
times x minus two squared
and we wanna make that equal to zero.
This is only going to be
true when x is equal to two.
So step two is looking good.
So step three, Olga says
f has an inflection point
at x equals two.
So she's basing this just on the fact
that the second derivative is
zero when x is equal to two.
She's basing this just on the fact
that f prime prime of
two is equal to zero.
Now, I have a problem with this
because the fact that
your second derivative
is zero at x equals two,
that makes two a nice
candidate to check out
but you can't immediately say
that we have an inflection point there.
Remember, an inflection
point is where we go
from being concave upwards
to concave downwards
or concave downwards to concave upwards
and speaking in the language
of the second derivative,
it means that the second
derivative changes signs
as we go from below x equals
two to above x equals two
but we have to test that
because it's not
necessarily always the case.
So let's actually test it.
Let's think about some intervals.
Intervals.
So let's think about the interval
when we go from negative infinity to two
and let's think about the interval
where we go from two to positive infinity.
If you want, you could
have some test values.
You could think about the sign,
sign of our second derivative
and then based on that, you
could think about concavity,
concavity of f.
So let's think about what's happening.
So you could take a test value.
Let's say one is in this interval
and let's say three is in this interval
and you could say one minus
two squared is going to be,
let's see, that's negative
one squared which is one
and then you're just going to,
this is just going to be 12
so this is going to be positive
and if you tried three,
three minus two squared is one times 12.
Well, that's also going to be positive
and so you're going to be concave upwards.
At least in these test values,
it looks like on either side of two
that the sign of the second derivative
is positive on either side
of the two and you might say,
well, maybe I just need
to find closer values
but if you inspect the
second derivative here,
you can see that this is
never going to be negative.
In fact, for any value
other than x equals two
and this value right
over here since we're,
even if x minus two is
negative, you're squaring it
which will make this entire thing positive
and then multiplying it
times a positive value.
So for any value other than x equals two,
the sign of our second
derivative is positive
which means that we're
going to be concave upwards
and so we actually don't
have an inflection point
at x equals two because
we are not switching signs
as we go from values
less than x equals two
to values greater than x equals two.
Our second derivative
is not switching sides.
So once again, this is incorrect.
We actually don't have an
inflection point at x equals two
because our second derivative
does not switch signs
as we cross x equals two
which means our concavity does not change.